hi guys Lucy here with the GameSpot news
update for you guess who's getting sued
again it seems the Australian
Competition and Consumer Commission
aren't all bowing at the altar of gaben
like the rest of us they're suing valve
over steams refund policy or distinct
lack thereof and it's alleged conflict
with Australian Consumer Law there were
three major issues that the ACCC took
umbrage with firstly that consumers were
not entitled to a refund for any game
sold by valve via Steam under any
circumstances so if you bought aliens
colonial Marines on Steam well that's
your own fault secondly that Valve had
excluded restricted or modified
statutory guarantees and/or warranties
the goods would be of acceptable quality
and finally that valve was not under any
obligation to repair replace or provide
a refund for a game where the consumer
had not contacted and attempted to
resolve the problems with the computer
game developer and the statutory
Consumer Guarantees did not apply to
games sold by valve ACCC chairman rod
Sims explains big media companies doing
business in Australia have to comply
with Australian Consumer Law point
number one is if you're going to do
business in Australia you have to comply
with Australian law the second is don't
have blanket conditions around the world
without bothering to check ooh
sick burn valves responded that they're
making every effort to cooperate with
Australian officials on the matter Sims
says the valve can now either negotiate
a quick settlement or fight the case in
courts saying they're a huge company
with massive resources so if they want
to fight it it could go on for one or
two years we'll wait and see what they
want to do so do you think valve are
gonna settle quickly and quietly are
they gonna put on their best suits and
heads of courts
let me know in the comments through all
the latest gaming rulings stay tuned
here to Law & Order GameSpot